[Musique]
le loup est névrosé et les vents
ravageuse l'universirant de texav revit
dans ce superbe livre de grand format
avec des dessins plein de et pour la
prièreis 400ents init césente des années
de recherche chez les collectionneurs du
monde
[Musique]
entier l'auteur Pierre Lambert s
intéressé aux années 1942
1955ép tra pour laro gold
ilu5ons aujourdhui des cl quz qu' dessin
pour donner une seconde de vie à Dr et
queb a signé la préface le prix de ce
monument paraîtra dérisoire Anecd en
vous connaissez Lee un des personnages
de la saga de lu ce juge célèbre dans
tout l'Ouest ex et l'un de ses
descendant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'app
[Musique]